julia ha recibido 40 dólares el número
de dólares que le quedan y después de
equis días está aproximado por la
fórmula de igual a 40 menos 25 x grafica
la ecuación y usa la gráfica para
estimar cuánto dinero le queda a julia
después de 8 días así que hagamos una
tabla de valores xy y después
utilizaremos esa tabla para realizar la
gráfica y así podemos responder la
pregunta que nos hacen de cuánto dinero
le queda después de 8 de hecho podríamos
hacer eso a través de la ecuación
lo haremos posterior x es el número de
días y como no vamos a regresar el
tiempo vamos a iniciar con x igual a 0
días así es que cuando han pasado 0 días
pues acaba de recibir el dinero
así es que ni siquiera tenemos que usar
la ecuación sabemos que al pasarse los
días al no haber pasado tiempo tiene 40
dólares pero bueno chequeamos lo con la
ecuación verifiquemos lo con la ecuación
y es igual a 40 menos 2.5 x vamos a
calcularlo para x igual a cero es 340
menos 2.5 por 0 este término se hace
cero así es que esto es 40 menos 0 igual
cuando no ha pasado el tiempo julia
tiene 40 dólares podríamos hacer ahora
para un día después pero aquí por esta
parte de la ecuación tendremos números
decimales así es que para que tengamos
números enteros hay que multiplicar esto
por múltiplos de dos así es que hagamos
para x igual a 2 para x igual a 2
el valor de lleva a ser 40 menos 2.5 2.5
por 2 y tenemos 2.5 por 25 así que 40
menos 5 le quedan 35 dólares pagamos
ahora x igual a 440 déjame hacerlo con
otro color para que cuando graphic hemos
los puntos veamos de dónde viene la
información así que cuando x igual a 4
tenemos 40 menos 2.5 por 4 2.5 por 4 es
igual a 10 40 menos 10 esto es igual a
30 dólares y observamos aquí que cada
dos días está gastando 5 dólares o lo
que es lo mismo 2.5 dólares diarios lo
podemos ver aquí con este signo menos
que representa que está gastando 2.5
dólares al día cada vez que se
incrementa x por 1 se gastan 2
5 dólares continuemos cuando x es igual
a 6 cuando x es igual a 6 días esto es
40 menos 2.5 por 62.5 por 6 es 15 40
menos 15 esto es igual a 25 dólares
sigamos hagamos el último cuando x es
igual a 88 días esto es 40 menos 2.5 por
8 2.5 por 8 es 20 40 menos 20 esto es
igual a 20 dólares de hecho que hemos
contestado a la pregunta después de ocho
días después de ocho días a julia le
quedan veinte dólares pero hagamos esta
primera parte gráfica hemos la ecuación
voy a dibujar entonces los ejes este es
mi eje vertical va a ser una gráfica
hecha a mano este es mi eje y que es los
dólares que le quedan y aquí tenemos el
eje horizontal que es el eje x y no
estamos enfocando únicamente en el
primer cuadrante porque en este contexto
estamos suponiendo que sólo va a tener
una cantidad positiva de dólares no va a
tener dólares negativos y también para
el caso de las equis que es el
díaz solo vamos a considerar valores
positivos de x por lo cual nos vamos a
enfocar en el primer cuadrante así es
que empezamos con ye igual a 40 para
este caso déjame primero poner la escala
del eje y empezamos con 10 voy a hacerlo
de 10 en 10 10 20 30
40 40 dólares marcamos ahora 35 25 15 y
5 hagamos ahora la escala para el eje x
tenga me usar el mismo color amarillo
así es que aquí tenemos x igualados
x igual a 4 x igual a 6 x igual a 8 x
igual a 10 vamos a graficar entonces los
puntos
cuando x es igual a cero días que es
igual a 40 dólares este es el punto 0,40
son las coordenadas de ese punto cuando
x es igual a 2 cuando x es igual a 2 y
es igual a 35 después de 2 días tiene 35
dólares cuando x es igual a 44 para la
equis que son los días de jaén pongamos
esta información en la gráfica el eje x
representa los días y el eje y
representa los dólares entonces cuando x
es igual a 4 que es igual a 30 ese es el
punto 4 30 cuando x igual a 6 para x
igual a 6 entonces y es igual a 25 es
este punto de aquí y finalmente después
de ocho días le quedan 20 dólares
después de ocho días le quedan 20
dólares ya que tenemos los puntos vamos
a conectarlos con una línea recta si
tuviéramos una regla necesitaríamos tan
solo dos puntos para tener una recta
adecuada dejamos el otro color para
trazar la gráfica conectamos los puntos
y obtenemos la línea que nos muestra
entonces cuánto dinero tiene julia cada
día hemos concluido hemos graficado la
ecuación y sabemos que después de ocho
días julia tiene 20 dólares